Without any further ado, let's get
started. So, everyone, I am Greg from
ENS Labs.
And today I'm going to be talking about
identity for apps, agents, and more with
ENS.
Um and so, let's get into it.
First of all, I'm going to start pretty
high-level. And I'm going to go through
what is ENS and then some things you can
use it for and maybe ideas of what to
build and then finally prizes. But,
first, what is ENS?
ENS, or the Ethereum Name Service, is a
decentralized, permissionless naming
protocol that lives on Ethereum, but
scales to the entire internet.
At a high level, we just turn complex
hex addresses into human-readable names.
And this is kind of the most simple use
of ENS. So, instead of having your
address be 0x19a886,
so on, and that is my Ethereum address,
um instead, my Ethereum account is just
gregsgrull.eth. Very easy
and much more usable.
And speaking of usable, ENS really
considers ourselves as a user experience
protocol. Yes, there's all this cool
tech and um smart contracts and code and
stuff, but ultimately we exist to make
the user experience of um Ethereum and
of crypto easier and better.
Um and I'll walk you through maybe an
example of that. So,
if I was at a cafe and got something
with a friend and I they they paid for
me, I would say, "Pay me back. Send $5
to 0x179a88627."
And I'm not going to read the whole
thing to bore you, but obviously that is
um not good. You that is hard to
understand, hard to hear, uh hard to
write, and even hard to copy and paste
or just like annoying to copy and paste.
Whereas the alternative is just saying,
"Send $5 to gregsgrull.eth."
Easy to understand,
easy to write, um easy to share, and so
on.
And ultimately it goes to the same
thing.
And this kind of simple mapping of, you
know, bringing a name to a hex address,
just name to address mapping is is very
simple. And that is what ENS started as,
a a very simple username for your kind
of Ethereum account.
But over time, it's really become this
profile rather than just a username.
And so, what do I mean by that?
I would say, um I mean that I can
attach, yes, an address, but also
any arbitrary data to my name. So, here,
this is my ENS profile. I have an image.
I have my name, a description of some
things that I do, like baking and
building apps on Web3 protocols.
And I have a list of addresses. That's
not just on one chain, but across many
EVM chains and many non-EVM chains.
I also have um
records that point to my social
accounts, like my X and GitHub, and so
on. Really, there's all of this metadata
associated with my name, which makes ENS
into my kind of decentralized Web3
portable profile.
And the way you see this normally in
applications, I guess like
websites,
is
this connect wallet button is very
common. You know, and when you press
connect wallet, if you don't have some
sort of identity associated with a
wallet,
the connected state might look like this
on the right. Really just a gray circle
and a pretty random set of characters,
which is your address.
And this is a bad experience. You know,
it's kind of like getting an email
where the intern forgets to fill out the
uh templated name
and it literally is just like, "Hey, um
first name or our customer's name that
we definitely care about." And this
never feels good. And this is what
crypto feels like without, you know,
ENS.
Um the alternative is you connect your
wallet and the application is able to
recognize your portable Web3 identity.
It's your name and your avatar and maybe
other metadata associated with your
name.
And this way, you feel kind of at home
when you're going across Web3. Your
profile is recognized immediately.
And it's better for the app because they
kind of know who they're working with
and they can show you a better
um view or give you a better user
experience, if you want to tie back to
the beginning.
These are a few examples of where you
might see it in the wild. Um ENS is
integrated into
hundreds of applications, but just a few
that kind of came to mind when I was
making this
are Snapshot and Matcha, two very big
apps, one in governance, one in DeFi,
completely unrelated. But um they both
support ENS to show you your profile
when you connect your wallet.
And this is just nice. It is a cohesive
experience across the ecosystem for me.
Um I should also say that if you have
any questions throughout this, feel free
to leave them in the chat and I will um
either answer it in real time if it's
relevant to whatever's on the screen or
I will answer them at the end.
So, should have said that at the
beginning, but we got it now.
Okay.
So,
where are we? More examples of using ENS
for two things that it's, you know, most
useful for.
And one on the left is a view of what
transaction history might look like
before you have ENS, basically with and
without. In the top two transactions,
it's very easy to see what's happening.
You can see that Greg is something is
sending something out to this other
name, zk.ens.gregsgrull.eth,
which actually is a smart contract
because, you know, ENS can name wallets,
but ENS can also name smart contracts.
And right below that,
you see that realcameron.eth
is sending something into
gregsgrull.eth. Very easy to understand
again. You can just glance at this and
know what's happening.
Whereas the bottom two are kind of just
completely random.
I have no idea what's happening here.
It's just one address sending something
to another.
And so, if you look at the kind of
before and after with and without ENS,
here,
um I think it's easy to draw a
conclusion that ENS improves the user
experience or improves the context of
these transactions.
And
on the right side, we see the opposite.
So, instead of,
you know, reading past transactions, you
are sending
current transactions, I guess.
And this is that whenever I'm sending
assets to another address,
I can simply type in a name
instead of copying and pasting an
address.
And yes, this is better for all the
reasons I described before, but also
safer. There is
less risk of just mistakenly typing one
character in a huge string rather than
typing a name that you probably already
know.
Okay. Quick water break.
Great.
So, the way we think about this overall
is that users of crypto-powered
experiences should never have to
interact with a hex address.
ENS is a user experience protocol, as I
said before,
and they should just be able to use
names everywhere.
And so, another way to say that is
anywhere you read or write a hex
address,
you should be able to use an ENS name
instead. And this is really what you
want to keep in mind as you're building.
Okay.
So, now we know kind of what is ENS,
let's cover how does it work?
There are two core processes in ENS.
There is forward resolution,
which is the process of a name going to
some sort of data.
For this example, let's just use
addresses.
And so,
this is showing that one name can point
to different addresses on different
chains, for example.
And forward resolution is going from a
name to data.
Then the reverse, we call reverse
resolution, um
fancy naming,
is the opposite of just going from an
address to a name.
And this mapping is also possible on a
number of chains,
um which is relevant for some sort of
addresses that don't exist on all
chains, like smart contracts. You can
have one name on
one chain for a given address and then
another name on another. Or it can only
apply on one overall.
And
the combination of these two things,
reverse resolution and forward
resolution, are what makes up a primary
name, as we call it. And a primary name
is what really is your identity across
Web3. This is what we were seeing in the
illustration before.
Um this is the before on the left-hand
side, the blank square
with pieces of my random address
going to my avatar with my name. This is
what's possible because of a primary
name.
And the way we configure primary names
is via these contracts that we call
reverse registrars.
And reverse registrars are available on
all the chains that you see here for
now.
The reverse registrar is just a very
simple contract that maps an address to
a name on a given chain.
And so, the interface, you know, very
simple, set name and set name for
address if you are doing it on behalf of
somebody else.
And this is kind of what enables the
core identity piece of ENS.
And so, that is basically what is ENS
and how does it work? And now, let's get
into the kind of how you use it um
area.
Which I had duplicate slides for, I
guess.
This is like how how do you how you can
use ENS? So, in the spirit of, you know,
ETHGlobal Open Agent Hackathon,
let's start with using it for agents.
Um
there are a number of features in ENS
that can be used obviously by humans or
agents, but these are just some ideas
specifically for agents.
It's very common, um as we've seen in
recent hackathons and are kind of seeing
throughout the space, for agents to have
their own name spaces or for people to
have agents underneath the their name
space. And so,
Workman, for example, is a colleague of
mine and he might have an agent that has
a crypto wallet. And obviously any
crypto wallet should have an ENS name.
And so, his agent is just
agent.workman.eth.
And there can be versions of these
agents or there could be sub agents to
your agent or you could have multiple
agents. So, it's like agent.workman.eth
and then under that could be V1 or it
could be like travel.agent.workman.eth
and that is your travel agent that has
access to book flights for you.
And then you can have
trade.agent.workman.eth
and this is your trading agent has
access to
trade whatever you might want.
And so on.
And so, this is the idea of having
agents as name spaces, basically. Um the
another setup for this, instead of
having agent under your own name, so
agent.workman.eth,
would be you have some app, so like your
project name.eth, basically,
and then under that you give you make it
easy for agents to create their own
name.
So, it would be like Greg's
agent.yourprojectname.eth for the sake
of the hackathon.
If your users come and don't already
have an ENS name, then you can basically
give them one on the spot.
Another use case for agents is agent
metadata. Um as I shared before with
text records, there or with just
ENS profiles in general, there are these
things called text records, which are
ways to store arbitrary data associated
with a name. And I think I'll talk a
little bit more about them in a minute.
But we have a spec called ENSIP-25,
um which you can find more about in this
QR code. Well, it's on the screen for
the next little while.
Which is basically a way to verify your
agent um is part of the 8004 agent
registry on a number of chains.
And this makes it possible to basically
verify that a name is a registered agent
and then therefore any of the records
associated with it are kind of um
confirmed in both directions. It closes
the verification loop between the name
and 8004.
And so, this is kind of a new
interesting thing that's worth looking
at for the hackathon.
Um
and yes, this
demo, ENSIP-25.ens.domains,
is kind of an interactive walk-through
of
showing that verification with the 8004
registry, if you're interested.
Not going to do a live demo of that
right now, though.
Another new thing in ENS to play with
that I think is increasingly important
with agents is
names for chains. And so,
as I said before, ENS works
um across the board, meaning that I can
set a base address or an optimism
address or a linea address on my ENS
name
and then when I'm sending assets to the
name on different chains, it can
basically know which addresses are
available.
But
a lot of the time
wallets or websites actually don't have
a great way to indicate the chain that
something is.
And so, if you go back to the coffee
example, if I say send me $5
to gregscholl.eth, it's like what what
chain do I want that on? What um
does does that matter? Do I have a
preference or do I not?
And these sort of things can be resolved
by interoperable names,
which work on ENS.
So, in ENS there's a special name called
on.eth. Fun fact, it is the only
two-character ENS name in existence.
And
the way it works is you append a name
with the chain name. And so, this is
effectively vitalik.eth at base.on.eth.
And that indicates that I actually want
you to send assets to Vitalik on base
rather than just Vitalik and you pick an
address from whatever's there.
Um so, it's kind of a new way to encode
addresses and a new way to have ENS be
the friendly way to name those
addresses. Um it is on the newer side
and there's not great adoption for it
now, but it's an interesting thing to
think about and therefore a great thing
to play around with at a hackathon.
A few other ideas um for things you can
build
are one, decentralized websites.
So, these are important because we're
learning more and more that um website
providers just go down. Between
Cloudflare or DNS providers or um
like domain issues,
the kind of whole website stack can
actually be pretty brittle and building
decentralized websites on ENS
is a way around this.
And really,
we're here to build protocols that live
forever, but the layer on top, which is
the front end, is often more brittle
than we think.
And so, I think it's an interesting
thing to play around with for
hackathons, how can your apps or agents
have more decentralized rails?
This is kind of a fancy diagram that is
maybe a little bit too overwhelming, um
that indicates the flow of building
decentralized websites on ENS.
There's this tool called Omnipin that is
kind of the orchestrator of all of these
things and so, I'm not going to bother
going too deep into it here,
but
if it's something that you're interested
in, please scan this QR code and I have
a whole talk dedicated to building
delete websites with ENS, where I talk
about Omnipin and IPFS and ENS and how
all of these things play together to
build decentralized applications.
I'll leave that up for a few more
seconds.
Okay, cool.
And I do see that we have a few
questions, but
not super relevant to what I've gone
over yet, so I'll answer them at the
end.
Um
next is naming contracts. I kind of
already mentioned this before, but when
most people think of ENS, they think
about naming wallets specifically or
really even more narrowly naming EOAs,
but ENS can be used to name any address
and that includes EOAs, smart accounts
and smart contracts of any sort. And
this helps enrich contract history when
looking at
transactions on block explorers
or using contracts as identity, if they
are you know, smart accounts.
So, this is an underexplored thing that
we'd love to see people use at
hackathons as well.
Sub names, I also talked about in a few
examples, like the agent registries,
um but ENS names can have infinitely
nested sub names.
And this allows you to onboard your
users to web3 in a simpler, cheaper way.
Um and this could be with a name
with a .eth name directly, like giving
your users name.eth,
or it could be by giving them sub names.
So, again, you have project your project
name.eth and then you give them
greg.yourprojectname.eth
or something like that.
And that could be on L1, on L2 or
entirely off chain.
A good tool for building sub names,
whether it's for issuing to your users
or issuing to your agents or anything
else,
um we have a cool tool called Durin,
which is basically a framework for
issuing ENS subdomains on any EVM chain.
Here's a QR code or the website is
durin.dev, d u r i n .dev.
This is a popular one at hackathons.
People seem to really like it.
I'm almost to the end, so thank you guys
for sticking with me. My voice is kind
of getting tired as well.
Um another thing that you can use is
custom text records to store metadata
with a name. I also mentioned this in
the agent section,
but basically any sort of data can be
persisted to an ENS name in the form of
text records. And so, a lot of the time
where you might think your decentralized
web your decentralized application might
need a database,
it could actually be solved by just
storing the data in ENS text records
instead. And this way, the identity of
your users is kind of the sole database
and that can be stored in a
decentralized way with ENS.
So, this I always find to be a fun one
to think about when you are kind of
architecting your data.
And so, with all of these building
blocks, um there are a number of things
that you can build, of course. And these
are, you know, large categories, but
features that might be applicable for
each.
So,
if you are building agents, then you
might want to give your agents a
username, a name, you know, whether
that's a sub name of your existing .eth
name, like we showed initially,
agent.workon.eth,
or
agent1.projectname.eth.
Um, any of those are usernames for
agents.
Agents could use text records to store
different types of metadata, like
payment preferences, where they want to
be paid, or what token they want to be
paid in,
or, um, when they were created, or what
launcher they used, or any of these
things.
And subnames are basically a way to
organize subagents or anything like
that.
For social, if you're building a social
app, of course you need usernames. You
want to show avatar images. In the
profile section, you probably want to
have metadata like a bio.
Um, these are all features that you can
build on top of ENS. And then you would
use primary names, of course, as the
identity of the app to show,
you know, when a user has posted, you
show their ENS name. Or when a user
engages, you show their ENS name. Uh,
the account ID is basically their EVM
account, like their EVM wallet address,
but the display name is effectively, or
their username is effectively, the ENS
name.
Um,
and wallet and con- uh, wallet is
similar. You would give your
use- you would give your users names,
and show their avatar, and show their
primary name.
And then lastly, content is kind of the
decentralized website conversation I was
talking about before.
Content hash is a record in ENS, which
you use to store IPFS
um, content pointers, and that is used
ultimately to serve a decentralized
website. This is stuff that I talk about
in that talk, um, from before where I
had the QR code.
Okay.
Um,
the thing to take away from this is
basically
anywhere your app or agent
interacts with a hex address, it should
instead show ENS names.
And so I think one of the questions here
was like, what sort of use cases are you
guys looking for? And really,
ENS is used to improve the user
experience of existing apps. It is less
common to build something specifically
on ENS, and more common to use it to
improve your existing app. And so, as
you're building your app, and you
encounter things that are just like
confusing, or have random addresses, or
you're needing to add a database for
each user, um, these are things that you
should stop and think, "Hmm, how can ENS
be used to improve this app, or to hide
this this hex address, or to improve the
user experience of my app, ultimately?"
Um,
those are the moments where ENS makes
the most sense.
And for building on ENS this weekend, we
have a number of prizes for you, which
I'm sure many of you have already looked
at. Um,
we have two tracks, the first of which
is best ENS integration, specifically
for AI agents.
Um, first, there is, I guess third,
there's a $500 prize, then a $750 prize,
and then a $1250 prize.
So, three winners for that track, and
three winners for the second track,
which is most creative use of ENS.
Similarly, there is a $500 prize, 750,
and 1250. And this could be anything
that you build, even if it's outside of
agents. There's a chance that most
creative use
and
best agent use are actually kind of the
same thing, in which case, um, there are
just six winners overall.
And so if they're all agents, then
great.
But there are six winners of ENS prizes,
um, that win up to $1250.
And that is my presentation. Perfect
timing, I have 5 minutes left for
questions. So, while I read through
this, thank you all for listening.
Okay.
Let's go up. Somebody asked early on,
um,
is there a way to store encrypted data
that only the address owner can see in
the metadata?
Um,
I mean, built into ENS, no. I would say,
similar to most of the Ethereum smart
contracts, everything is public in ENS
by default.
There are interesting ways
of doing privacy in ENS. Um, one of my
favorite examples that I always like to
share is Fluidkey. Um, and I know I'm
not sharing my entire screen, so you
can't see
what I'm typing into the browser right
now, but I will paste the link in the
chat.
Um,
this
Fluidkey is basically a privacy layer on
top of ENS, that every time you resolve
a name, it points to, or it resolves to
a new address, and that address is a
stealth address,
so that the owner of the name can
ultimately access all of the funds
really seamlessly together.
But from the outside, if I send
something to a Fluidkey name, like if I
send ETH to a Fluidkey
ENS name,
and then you send ETH to a Fluidkey ENS
name, those will actually go to two
different addresses on chain. And so we
can't see that each other sent
something, but ultimately the owner of
the name
can access both of the funds seamlessly.
Uh, and so this is always like a super
cool example that I like to share, and
that is honestly one of my favorite
hackathon projects of all time on ENS,
and they've gone on to, um,
build it out as as a business over time.
Um, and so it's
very cool. I I recommend looking at that
one.
Um, somebody else asked, "What are some
examples of the killer use cases that
ENS is looking to explore?"
Yeah, I think this is, um, going back to
here. It's like, most of the time, ENS
is used to improve your existing app,
and not be a super fancy thing just on
top of ENS itself.
Uh, and really the the killer use case
of ENS is
im- improving the user experience of
crypto. And so, whatever that might mean
to you, is, um, probably my best answer
here. I don't have a specific thing of
like, you should build this app where
it's all about ENS. That's actually not
the goal. Um, ENS is kind of like the
integration layer. And so, I would say
that answer very much depends on
the app you're building.
Um, Joel asked, "Is there a way to
verify the ENS names on chain?"
Hmm. I'm not entirely sure what you mean
by verify the ENS names. Um, maybe you
can
m- send that in the message as a
follow-up. But inherently, ENS is on
chain, and so,
um, I
think my soft answer is going to be yes.
And if you give more info, then I can
and try and give a more specific answer.
Um, can we set custom metadata for
usernames?
Yes. I think that is basically the text
records that I was talking about. And if
I go back
all the way over
here to my ENS profile,
um,
I don't have a great example, actually,
but in this other records section,
would show up anything that is not,
um, kind of our default social records.
So,
for example, a text record is just a
key-value pair of a string to a string.
I could set the key to be
blah,
or like the key to be foo, if I want to
have a better example, and the value to
be bar. And that is custom metadata for
ENS names,
um,
and this can kind of
go to any extent. So, I can set like my
payment preferences here, like I said
before.
For example, I could set that I always
want my swaps to output to some certain
pair on a certain chain, or a certain
token on a certain chain. And then if
you're building a DeFi app,
you can look at the text record of the
ENS name that's been connected to the
website,
and read those preferences, so that it's
kind of a durable storage across
um, DeFi websites. And if I go to
another DeFi website, they can read the
same records. And this is, um,
kind of confirming the point that I was
saying, ENS is your portable portable
profile across Web3.
You can set any metadata you want on any
name, and then any app can access that.
Um, so Amir, I hope that answers your
question.
Um,
let's see.
Arun asked, "Has ENS been used in the
dance industry in large scale?"
I don't
believe so, not that I know of. Um,
so if you're building something in the
dance industry, you can you can be the
first.
Um,
good example is Fluidkey. Great, I'm
glad you guys like that.
Here. Um, what is the recommended
pattern for using CCIP read to write
updates to off-chain names, or to write
updates to off-chain storage that are
then verified on chain?
Okay, so
um,
there's probably more stuff to unpack
there, so I'm going to, um, suggest that
you message it in Discord, and and we
can help. I think like,
ultimately, CCIP read
is a spec that allows you to have ENS
data off-chain. And so, for example, my
name could be gregsgould.eth, but all of
the records, everything else that you
see on this page, could be served from
an L2, or from a centralized database,
if you wanted it to, or anything like
that. Um CCIP read is basically the
protocol that allows you to do that.
And there is no equivalent CCIP write,
which it sounds like you might be asking
about.
Uh ultimately,
yeah, there might not be a perfect
solution for you,
but happy to explore more in in Discord.
Part of CCIP read is a verification
flow, but again, that's just on the read
part, not the write part. And so, I
don't want to go too in-depth if that's
not what you're asking about.
Um
Okay.
Somebody asked if my personal website is
decentralized. Um
so,
gregskril.com, which is what you linked,
is not an example of a decentralized
website.
gregskril.eth
would be my decentralized website. And
the way you access decentralized
websites, um without having any sort of
special software on your computer, is
through gateways like eth.limo or
eth.link. And what these basically do is
just um proxy the content. So,
gregskril.eth.limo,
eth.limo is a service that takes the
bottom half, so gregskril.eth, it
fetches the content hash, which I
mentioned earlier is a pointer to IPFS
content, and then just serves it under
an easy domain, so that users don't have
to install special software on their
computer.
And so, that would be an example of a
decentralized website, not exactly my
gregskril.com.
And the biggest example of this is
Vitalik uh himself. He shares blog posts
as vitalik.eth.limo,
which is his decentralized website, and
the content for that is managed under
his ENS name, vitalik.eth.
Um are you doing I know we're getting
over time, so I'll be done in just a
second. Thank you, Pascal, for hanging
around. Um Bruce asked, "Are you doing
office hours to review projects, which
is gregskril.eth?" Um we will be at the
project feedback session tomorrow. I
don't know exactly what time that is,
but um I know it's coming up. And I
don't think we have any specific office
hours, but if you have questions or want
feedback, please post it in the Discord,
and we will get back to you there.